I believe that large social gatherings
should not be allowed to go on in the
middle of a pandemic
it is of course very difficult to assess
when it will be safe to initiate again
these events the whole wedding industry
is under extreme threat at the moment
and that's 139 thousand businesses 2020
was meant to be one of the biggest years
on record for the wedding industry but
no one could have predicted what would
come next
the corona virus is the biggest threat
this country has faced over four decades
and will stop all social events
including weddings baptisms and other
ceremonies lock downs and limits on
social gatherings have sent the wedding
industry into turmoil 76 percent of
weddings between April and July have
been postponed and 13 percent have been
cancelled so I wanted to find out how
the industry is planning to bounce back
from the pandemic and to speak to the
couples and businesses who have been
affected my first visit was to a
family-run wedding planning business in
North London who specialized in
organizing Mediterranean weddings from
around 200 to 300 guests it's an
interesting thing to talk about socially
distant stands for because I don't think
you made manage to facilitate that
Mediterranean wedding there love a party
and I love everybody you know to go
there and enjoy themselves they have a
lot of family visiting from abroad as
well the weddings are still a massive
part of the culture and where there used
to be you know my father's original days
and my grandfather's time it was a
thousand people sometimes their parents
have saved up for generations especially
in the Mediterranean world for them to
hostess wedding from from the get-go
once we heard about coronavirus being
present in the UK the right decision
without brides and grooms was to
postpone their weddings now we're facing
the scenarios before for various reason
the difference in this case is that
you've got you know an entire calendar
year for a venue as well as needing to
move under new government guidelines
ceremonies of up to 30 people have been
allowed to
but in their current form for many
businesses weddings simply aren't
profitable the current advice means no
receptions all parties should take place
after exchanging vows and ceremony
should be kept as short as reasonably
possible the guidance also advises
against consuming food or drinks and
singing and shouting is to be avoided
for many it is far from an ideal wedding
okay so we just found an ice cream van
hit the jackpot this is Gabriela and
leafing from West Yorkshire they met
each other in 2016 at a university ball
in Oxford he stepped on the back of my
foot when I was done saying for those
that is China bit far and get to know
each other better and we managed to
reconnect when we were back in well
actually and yeah I didn't take much
time in sliding into the DMZ yeah right
after getting engaged two years later
they had been planning a wedding for 200
people in March of this year but then
they got some bad news the same day we
were picking up the keys to our new flat
I had this welcome through the door from
all the owners of the venue saying that
they need to close the venue they didn't
have the correct planning permissions
they weren't allowed to be built there
an ancient battle happened on the field
where the venue is we did all the
invitations how its first funded by the
venue oh this is horrible like this is
all going wrong after finding a new
venue of just two months ago they were
then hit with some more unexpected news
[Music]
Gabriela and defend postponed their
wedding from March to September this
year but have now had to make the
agonizing decision to postpone again to
next year they felt that with social
distancing likely to still be in place
he
have been the day they had paid for or
envisioned but for those couples without
big guest lists and unable to wait
virtual platforms have offered
innovative new ways of getting married
during the pandemic as well as virtual
weddings we've seen elopements
drive-through weddings and intimate
backyard Affairs but will this trend
live on pass the pandemic to find out
more I set up a call with Hamish Shepard
the founder of bribe book a wedding
planning out for engaged couples do you
think coronavirus world changed the
wedding industry permanently it's hard
to tell yet but the definitely changes
because expect see depends over time one
of the things that was seeing after the
credit crunch was a big trend in more
DIY weddings if people are more cost
sensitive over over the next year or two
that's where the boho trend and weddings
actually sort of very much originated in
one thing I think you'll definitely see
is more intimacy or intimate weddings
what we're all missing out is
exemplified in many ways by our wedding
people gathering celebrating as family
celebrating love and for it to be taken
ways is going to feel very difficult for
everyone for couples who have had their
wedding day postponed many are still
marking their original dates in what is
often an emotional time to reflect on
what would have been this is Marisa and
Ian celebrating their would have been
wedding day with a commitment ceremony
they were due to be married at the
Italian villa a venue on the south coast
of England but in the process of
rearranging their big day the owners of
their venue went into administration
by the current viruses that you don't
know it was gonna come next or what's
gonna happen
we've we thought we were okay we managed
to move are they originally planned all
of a sudden when they only went into
administration it was it's quite a shot
with our venue going to administration
which was due to cope at 19 it made it a
lot more difficult I think that we
initially thought or the hardest things
of when your wedding has been impacted
by and covert 19 is because of what's
going on in the world and you know there
are some terrible things happening to
people you kind of fill up maybe you're
not allowed to be upset because in the
grand scheme of things it isn't the
biggest deal but to us it was a big deal
and you know we're just really looking
forward to to getting on with planning
and as much as it has been stressful and
emotional I think it's made us realize
it's probably more important and than
ever
it's one of your ties one of the guests
wedding time not being able to see your
friends and family for so long has made
me appreciate them even more and it's
made me think it'll be great when we can
all reunite and our wedding would be a
great excuse for everyone to reunite
we've got friends and family all over
the world all over the country so it's
the perfect excuse for who could get
together the Italian villa has now been
taken over by new owners and in a
statement to Sky News Beals gourmet the
venue's former owners say they acted in
the best interests of their clients by
going into administration they said we
have worked tirelessly over the last 15
years to build our business up and we
could not have predicted the corona
virus pandemic or its effects we have
always been immensely proud of our
business and to lose it like this is
devastating for us
according to bribe book the wedding
industry is set to lose up to eighty
seven and a half billion pounds in
revenue this year and the sad reality is
many businesses may not survive a drop
in income dislodge the industry really
is having an extremely difficult time
and need support it was going into its
busiest parish the summer season is when
80 percent of weddings happen and that's
been you know pretty much wiped out on
the basis of of when social gathering
will be limited until so it's extremely
challenging we found with some of the
more kind of bespoke venues that aren't
part of a big chain it's been much more
of a challenge for them because just
like us as a small family business they
depend on that income so it's been more
changing perhaps the smaller locations
compared to the more established ones as
the wall begins to recover from the
pandemic couples families and businesses
are hopeful that they will be able to
celebrate love in the not-too-distant
future it may not be what they had
originally hopeful all planned but maybe
just maybe it could be even better 2020
is definitely going to be possibly the
hardest year for the wedding industry
ever 2021 I hope is gonna be the
greatest year for the wedding industry
ever although we work on so many events
you remember every specific one every
couple and you do you do know them for
the rest of your life so it's a really
nice thing to see them happy especially
after the pandemic as well to think you
know one day they'll be able to tell
your kids you won't believe what happens
mom and dad's wedding it got postponed
because of this crazy pandemic that took
place and it'll make it I think even
more memorable
[Music]